Daanish being da judge he gets inside my
school find the powell third board the
game from Luca who averages a team-best
11 again 3/4 they were together for a
long time Nico shakes free for the
defendant to transit 3
happens to you when you are primarily a
perimeter shooter let's face it as Luke
urges he's gonna play tonight
does it points for Aldrich but the star
of the show so far looking with 14
points looking for
- it hands-on when those two guys are on
the floor that's for sure looked a
change of direction to get into the pain
and right back into the game and tacking
on to board with 17 points did he had in
the first quarter it's in the house vise
the trap closed Pont about this guy here
you just said thirty all the way here's
look at changing direction in the paint
should we buy the Mavericks San Antonio
scrambles forward and here comes a guy
doing it pretty snip Toluca docket and
then the open trails great fine after
getting in the lane the durian has been
outstanding shoes the basketball tonight
to alter the shot
birdy would be jealous
attacking hit the paint again tonight
wait until the final seconds on well
start to finish
she's been sensational there's no
question about that still tapped it over
to Seth Curry to put a lid on this win
and you know there's certain guys
certain coaches certain players of the
league that they're like you have 14
games that leads the NBA one ahead of
LeBron James James picked up his fifth
last night and now has a triple-double
against every NBA team
Don shipped with six foot points my
goodness I mean there is just they're
given they're just overmatched right now
they've got to find some spirit some
energy really nice pass
now Sydow as he sees another step back
by daunted the beautiful kick out to
Jackson no good but John's hitch gets
the rebound goes back up and finishes
what can you do tonight left
and look how smooth that stroke is we
set at some point he was going to get
the three points he gets to the rim
fakes the pass by Luca gotcha
I have no idea like what would you say I
mean your team's you're short-handed you
really want me to tell you what I would
say and get fire
Jen coming off to his right they're
trying to trap him bengis them right off
the dribble the LOB it's just great
field great vision power he plays with a
real edge which is no surprise Avery
Johnson coached in the college to the
basket of course you would be free for
free when you get opportunities like
this to school
Luca probit in the lane of drawing
defense lobbing it up there's another
look at Luca sink level of superstardom
no one ever tried to make it less about
themselves
[Applause]
Dallas's second three tonight the
business section classifieds in there
some funny papers foreskin oh yeah I
love Ziggy that's five four two three
five goes to Tim Hardaway jr. 85 to Tim
he's good right now the way he shot
three to the last two games night for
his last 10 I know he's gonna have to do
it on a bigger stage he's gonna have to
prove it Thank You Luka
[Music]
dribble handoff stop it Papa it says
first Oh Jalen is probably coming in for
him inside good defense by Dallas
quickly out of the
four batches and to stay on dodging
dodge it steps back
PJ gets in his landing spaceman budgets
the hug sit down on the glass floor see
honest who won the MVP last season when
harden averaged 36 dodge is the favorite
player flavor this year for the mattress
I just walked him right in that's how
strong he is
hesitating and then throwing up to this
lob man right there Maxie cleaver
hobbies of Antonio but he did have a
trip with San Antonio and there's
switched off diamonds now there's no
help defender in there to protect the
rim you see Austin coming over
on the
gox's who walks his way down for 2m long
his trip and watch porzingis cutting it
along the baseline and he's tall enough
look at his head hard and thousand right
there 1 2 3 steps actually he actually
traveled after slow down right laughs
slow down and then it gets clobbered in
the face by Westbrook a Miami Heat
coming in Wednesday and you know what
Miami did to Houston